[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
analyzing highly multiplexed and
multimodal spatialomix chip cytometry
data sets
i am kaylee bach of labrutz and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by canopy biosciences a broker
company
to learn more visit
canopybiosciences.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
john spencer schwarz product manager
chip cytometry instrumentation at canopy
biosciences
spencer you may now begin your
presentation
hi
my name is john schwarz i'm a product
manager for canopy biosciences
uh specifically serving the
instrumentation and software products
for our spatial offerings
so cellscape really represents uh the
continuation of a decade and a half long
journey to bring chip cytometry kind of
where it is today
so again the cell skate can collect the
same biologically relevant data set very
high spatial resolution very high
dynamic range imaging you can still use
anyone's antibodies which makes it
economically uh efficient as well as
very versatile now it just goes uh
at a speed at a throughput so it can
actually keep up with experiments that
are being performed here and now
so to start here uh just an overview of
kind of physically what we do with these
samples
um so we can look at either a cell
suspension or alternatively a tissue
sample essentially anything that you can
section and put onto a slide or anything
that you can pipet is something we can
work with
uh we then go through these rounds of
five plus iterations where we will stain
with five antibodies at a time uh we
will image uh we will then photo bleach
and google image again
at any point in the cycle
just because of the way we're doing this
you can of course
pull the sample off of the instrument
and actually store that in the case of
cell suspension since we've done all our
validation data in uh for cell
substantial is actually up to 36 months
at this time
um because we're using base fluorescence
uh and we're only using five channels
instead of a bunch of different channels
and trying to unmix them or anything
like that
it really opens you up to being able to
basically use thing that fluoresces in
those five channels which also means
that we can take a look at mixed
modality detection uh so of course uh
taking a look at rna as well as protein
is uh what absolutely everyone wants to
do right now very very popular which
makes a ton of sense um but consider
cases where uh you know maybe uh maybe
you have interleukin or some other
cytokine uh that is actually dispersed
into the cells
uh excuse me enter the interstitium um
if that's the case then it's very
difficult to associate that signal which
would be you know very diffuse through
uh this entire uh sample associate that
with a particular cell and quantify it
the ability to combine rna and protein
together
makes it very easy to quantify uh the
expression level via
rna signature uh with the expression of
protein with direct detection
uh really really excited to show this to
you guys so the cell skate can actually
collect images at 182 nanometers per
pixel
uh so this image is absolutely crisp uh
we're actually able to collect here if
you look at the cellular features um so
what i'm personally really excited about
this or why i'm really excited about
this is you know at 500 nanometers per
pixel you can certainly do cytometry
with this that's no problem uh you can
separate individual
cells you can also tell the difference
between two cells and kind of a sign
signal accordingly
um 182 nanometers per pixel allows us to
do is truly say that we have
sub-cellular resolution
i've tried to pick out one of these
little features here to kind of
illustrate that but the ability to see
these smaller subcellular features is
what's going to i think powerful the
next step of chip cytometry and the next
step of psychometry in general uh which
is not just locating where a signal is
on a cell by locating where a signal is
in a cell i find that very very exciting
um so the entire optical train the
camera uh the optics as well as the
objective
gives you basically this high resolution
image at 180 nanometers per pixel it
gives you very efficiently
and it gives you over this huge huge
field of view so that we can collect
these data sets that are very very high
spatial acuity very high hdr or very
high signal to noise we can also collect
them very efficiently
so that's essentially kind of the
introduction of cellscape
so you can still use versatile reagents
from trusted vendors you do your
biologin uh this
also applies to anything that's either
uh you know an exotic marker or
alternatively an exotic model per se
we can still give you uh biologically
relevant data meaning hdr imaging and
very very high spatial acuity data now
but what we've done here is especially
the cell skate is engineered for
practical implementation
so this last talk is to spend a little
bit of time talking about uh chip
cytometry data analysis um so we'll kind
of break this into three sections uh the
first is kind of going over the utility
of the uh just kind of gross overview
the utility of the um zkw app uh
analysis features so basically what's on
board the instrument
uh after that i'd like to talk a little
bit about um
extending this data set
because the
features or the applications that are
actually supported by this data set uh
far exceed what is actually included
within the software
when you consider that it's hdr data
that you get um all the different kind
of uh ways you can slice and dice our
data sets uh they end up being really
really powerful
um and then we'll kind of end uh with a
few examples of kind of what you can do
with this and then a little bit of a
discussion as far as kind of where we're
going uh with uh with data analysis for
chip cytometry in the future
um so let's maybe start with the uh kind
of standard pipelining
but i wanted to start here uh just with
cells
the reason being that this tool set was
actually designed to work with cells
um so
it's uh
in most cases segmenting uh these cells
actually doing a pretty good job um so
this is cd45 um that was stained on pbm
steve's um but the thing to consider
here is actually the image that's being
processed with our segmentation protocol
is actually the transmitted light image
um
what's cool about this
there we are uh what i found very kind
of unique about this is this actually
was you know a very nice application of
artificial intelligence
so you know there's no great intensity
difference between kind of cells and
background here it all is all the
information as to what's a cell and
what's not a cell is really encoded in
the shape
uh the shape of those cells and kind of
the the gradations across the field here
uh what i think is interesting about
this though is if we bring up the
segmentation actually works quite well
um so we can not only find these
individual cells it can actually you
know like uh it can exclude cells that
are the wrong shape because of their
ptosis it can accelerate cells that are
along size um it doesn't actually really
really good job at finding cells
in a in a bright field image
so we can take this data and really the
idea again is is truly uh or the
pipeline i should say the tools are
really uh set up to do cytometry uh so
let's take this image um this microscopy
image and let's do cytometry with it uh
so again for each of these cells that
have been identified i get expression
values for every single one of them
i can then cast those as dot plots you
can see um
to kind of rebuild these plots
uh we can see that we actually get
really really good grouping of when we
have a cell suspension like this and
it's very easy in typical cases to make
uh calls between populations
on top of that even when we get into
more complicated uh you know and more
difficult to uh discern uh population
differences um you can actually use kind
of communication between uh this
population or uh this intensity
profile or this intensity. and of course
the
images uh image data which are
have their binaries located so for each
of these uh to kind of
essentially cross-correlate your your
results here
so you know i can kind of go back to
this uh image
set and i can
let's see here
click click click away here uh so let's
go back to the hdr image um and we can
take a look at something simple like uh
you know who's a who's a leukocyte uh
then maybe we'll also add a
t-set of toxic t-helper cells
uh and maybe we can kind of take a look
at those t
okay but this guy let's get rid of this
guy
uh so i should of course be able to
bring up then let's take a look here and
find cd4 and cd8
here's cd4 very nice
and then also cd
[Music]
yeah so here you can tell we
differentially um you know identify
these individual populations so again
the you know the the pipeline is already
really really good at doing this um so
once you get a nice segmentation of
yourselves you have all the tools uh
kind of at your disposal as uh on board
in order to do this sort of work
um
where it becomes complicated is uh if we
go to the uh
if we go to the
tissue case
so the same set of tools is actually
available for tissue analysis
uh but you'll notice if you take a look
at these tissue plots the overlap
between uh the
the two signals any two signals
essentially is much much closer in the
case of tissue than it is in the case of
cells
and this has everything to do with the
[Music]
tissue segmentation algorithm that's
implemented within the software suite
currently
um
so if you'll take a look at this uh
really the issue that we have here if we
take a look at that same graph
of cd4 versus cdt cells we'll count and
bring up a few of those guys here
but if i cast some of those gates let's
do something that's easily
indistinguishable or distinguishable
rather let's do immune cell versus
epithelial cells
and show our segmentation
so
um even with pretty decent segmentation
you can see where you get the uh
uh cells rather that are very closely
opposed to each other so this is what
we're really referring to when we say
spectral or excuse me spatial uh spatial
spillover spatial overlap um
depending on you know what you call what
cell in this individual uh and each of
these images you're going to get
your binaries uh overlapping to some
extent
uh i would mention too that so in this
particular case the the size of these
are are not actually uh truly indicative
of the segmentation so i'll bring that
up too just so you can kind of see what
the actual raw segmentation is
yeah
uh so here we're still basing this on a
nuclear nuclear stain
as we kind of described before perfect
but what you'll find is that even though
we're not drawing perfect cell shapes
again we can still do a pretty decent
job at pulling out individual
populations uh we're also demarking
those populations within the
imaging uh the the image rather
so that we can go back and forth just
like we can with cells and we can delete
cells we can appropriately segment cells
into their individual compartments
okay
so either with the cells or with tissue
uh the next step or actually you know
once we've done uh a an analysis uh that
we're we're happy with uh we come out
with uh individual populations that
we're happy with uh the next step is uh
exploring those results um so
there's a couple of ways that we can do
this uh the first if you're truly just
interested in you know kind of the
internal pipeline and i have x amount of
phenotypes uh and i want to export them
easiest way to do that of course is just
print statistics so i'll decide i want
to look at all my gates select all
right all the metadata to those and i
can immediately
onboard
get
descriptors about the populations that i
have uh
demarked um so for each one of these uh
you get a designation of gate you get
the total cells in the gate um you also
get the percentage of the all gates so
all the cells that you identified and
then percentages of the parent gauge so
you get that immediately tension of this
internal pipeline is really or the
utility of the internal pipeline is
really to
give access to these
multiplex cytometry tools to those that
are maybe you know not image analysis
experts in the first place um that would
find it challenging to come up with
their own image analysis pipeline and if
you look at it from that perspective
it's actually a rather full-featured set
of tools it can get you all the way from
images to actually running through
populations
however as we've kind of gotten into
this and developed the software
development platform
we do of course realize that our there
are more powerful software platforms out
there there are machine learning
algorithms out there
that can do segmentation in tissue
better
so again you know this gives a
kind of a novice user a first taste and
how to do this sort of work
so that they can use those kind of
introductory skills to to build their
pipelines accordingly
um and you know there's several people
or several customers out there that use
this internal pipeline uh to great
effect
uh but of course you know we do not want
to limit uh
your data or your analysis to kind of
our tool set uh that's definitely not
the intention
um so there's a there's a couple of very
unique features uh to this chip
cytometry data set that makes it very um
highly extensible as i put it there's a
lot that you can do with it
um first of course is you know hdr image
acquisition uh but essentially the same
image
set or same composite you're going to
get the dimmest of the denim cells well
outside when you could capture with one
exposure and you're going to get the
brightest the bright cells
well outside what you can capture in one
exposure all fused together
another aspect of this data set though
is that because of the cyclic nature of
the staining and imaging and then photo
bleaching
uh this allows us for every round of
imaging to actually collect more than
just the net fluorescence that you might
see in uh
that's typically published
um so
we also must in order to give you good
quantitative information we must collect
the background image here so we uh have
that available for export um we can also
give you the uncorrected fluorescence as
well as the uh of course the uh
what we talked about the net
fluorescence i'm kind of not shown here
also the transmitted light image
but the idea here is you get that in
32-bit for every single imaging round so
it's just a ton of crisp in the middle
for kind of higher end image analysis
applications
artificial intelligence and machine
learning particularly can definitely
benefit from a data set that's bridged
like this we also go to kind of great
efforts to make sure that um you can use
these data uh to their best benefit um
so we've made sure that they're actually
compatible with
uh essentially every uh
commercial and every open source uh
platform that we can get our hands on
so we know for example that these data
sets work very well with indica lance
halo we know that they work with visio
farm we know that they work in is
elements and the reason this is
important is because a lot of people
already have pipelines that they're
using and they don't necessarily uh want
to nor should they have to we uh
reinvent the wheel just to use our
software uh so instead we just make the
full raw in its full glory by image that
available available
to you for easy
import
so in this case we're taking a look at
nis elements uh this is kind of nis
elements used for whole slide
segmentation
then mean intensity calculation and then
they have a lot of nice data display
features um that were used to generate
this heat map uh where we're taking a
look at in this case pancetta keratin
and then alternatively at the same data
set taking a look at breast cancer
excuse me cd45
so i thought this might be kind of nice
to show
it's just to run this
it's just a little algorithm uh i did
this last night not super fancy
where i could do something as simple as
like just draw
circle
accept it
it'll think about stuff for a second
and instead of having the analysis over
the entire
piece of tissue it is instead going to
just truncate that to this uh this spot
um so we can do things like you know
take a look at a uh a tma and then have
it automatically find the individual
spots in tma and then separate those
analyses
by itself
what's cool about what's coming though
is that that in itself basically just
means that we could analyze this using
this software which is you know kind of
beside the point but what we've come up
with is a scheme to actually take this
segmentation take this binary and
actually import it back into
zellcraftwork so the other thing that we
might do as far as distance uh so i also
did a nice look
a lovely little example here just on
distance uh distance matrixes
um so same deal i'll maybe draw a little
smaller circle uh that way it's a little
more dramatic here
and hit run
so the other thing this has is kind of
some post binary processing tools uh and
uh post um
uh
post binary or post analysis uh
visualization tools here which this
takes a little bit longer to run on my
machine
but basically what i've asked it to do
is calculate the distance between
uh every nuclei that is found in that
little spot
and then color the uh color the
nuclei binary accordingly
so that's what we've got here
uh sin most certainly goes for open
source
pipelines
so we know of course that because it's a
noamy tiff uh this works in image j it
works in q path it works in cell
profiler uh here is just an example uh
this is also one of that same uh
paper of the technical university in
munich um using kind of the power of
imagej an open pipeline in order to do
some very uh specific and very powerful
cell segmentation and further analysis
uh so in this case you know these just
kind of showing standard segmentation
this is using stardust
versus his kind of augmentation of this
where he's actually
using two separate pipeline in order to
segment uh
epithelia uh versus immune cells and in
doing so he's just greatly increased the
number of cells identified uh which cuts
down on double positives cuts down on
this rare cells that you might be losing
out on uh generally provides you a
better solution than if you just
segmented than the word uh biased
publication uh turns out uh that same uh
kind of base algorithm of stardust is
also uh included in qpath uh which is a
nice easy free uh software package for
looking at
primarily pathology samples but it's
very nice we're looking at very very
large images um that are both both large
in size as well as larger numbers and
channels
uh finally our internal pipeline is also
exportable the results of our internal
pipeline are also exportable so if you
go through image segmentation uh
phenotyping through bivariate gating um
and taking a look at those individual
populations really what you're doing is
generating a list mode version of
your data
um so if we take a look at that as a raw
file which every cell has a positive id
every cell has an x and y value
associated with it it's got size um it
has the values of every single thing
that we collected
so this essentially kind of digitizes
your uh
digitizes your your um
data
um and you really can so you know this
is kind of a map of our uh image and you
can use this information then to
actually make a map of these cells now
when you look at it on aggregate it
actually does a pretty good job of
mapping out this tissue
so we can actually
export
as a basically a digital digitalized
version of this
map or cell map
um so this is looking at the all gate
but we can also do this for any of the
analyses or any of the populations that
we found
we can then cast that as just a digital
version
this pairs very well with
more bioinformatics type pipelines that
are really just looking for raw data
basically at that point the sample is
essentially digitized
so you can generate very easily plots
that maybe take a look uh look like this
at locations themselves and you're
looking at their expression values
um but what this can power uh is things
like uh unsupervised clustering uh in
this case we're taking a look at an
example of chip cytometry data put
through a umap
algorithm in order to identify clusters
kind of de novo
in this case he was taking a look at his
non-corrected versus
corrected data sets just to show that
the clustering actually did increase
when you did his correction um as well
as then the number of
clusters versus the silhouette score
all to say that he's improved it with
this uh new segmentation technique
everything from the images themselves
all the way through the pipeline with
chip cytometry is easy to export in
summary um the zkw app
still provides a lot of the
functionality the same functionality of
course uh through cellscape that it does
and did through the cell scanner so we
have onboard an analysis pipeline that
will take you from
compiling images all the way through
getting populations out of those
of course i also hope i showed you the
extensibility of that data set um
through a couple of examples of what you
can do with that data outside the zkw uh
pipeline
uh and that it has you know kind of base
compatibility both 16-bit and i think
importantly 32-bit so you can actually
get to the raw hdr files uh but
compatibility with image j compatibility
with uh
visio farm uh essentially anyone that
can import a
uh ome tip
um i really appreciate your time again
and uh i hope you have a lovely evening
thank you
thank you spencer for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen we'll
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for
all right let's get started our first
question asks do you have a list of
recommended tools for working with chip
cytometry data
okay
i do yeah um
and that's
locating those tools uh can be a bit of
a bear um i'd say the best resource
for people that i've seen so far um is
actually an article that uh was
published it's in the bioarabics
that basically just lays out each of the
tools that are available uh kind of
as of about a month ago
but most importantly kind of lays them
out
in categories that
are we'll say you know how how
complicated or how extensive is that
software package um
because the
the problem is when you look at the tool
set that people publish a lot of times
it's very difficult to tell whether
they're talking about uh something as
simple as a function or a component of a
piece of software
or or an entirely uh
an entire software suite
you have to do a bit of digging to kind
of get at that answer
so that's something i can kind of add uh
as i'll add that link uh as an answer to
that question
um
but
that's probably the best place i would
say to look um as far as a short list um
for uh specifically multiplexed image
sets uh really cutepath seems to be the
best as far as um open source imaging uh
pipelines uh it's basically kind of a
it's built on top of image j
but specifically for looking at these
very large data sets that are in both
large and in size uh as well as numbers
of channels
um
if you want to go for a paid option i
certainly recommend halo or visio farm
those are kind of purpose-built for this
kind of stuff too uh and the difference
between the two is essentially whether
you want your resources to go into
personal time or you uh just
essentially about paying paying for
support
um so if you have lots of time in your
hands and the intention is to learn how
to make these pipelines and how to
employ them and i would definitely go
the open source route if you're really
just looking to employ pipelines i'd
probably go for a paid uh a a pay for
service or a pay for platform
great thank you spencer another question
we have here asks what are the
advantages of hdr imaging in spatial
biology
yeah absolutely um we've really kind of
found this to be essentially you know
it's essential to uh doing this
correctly
um and the issue is not necessarily like
the sensitivity of the camera or the bit
depth of the camera it's nothing to do
with kind of the physics of the
instruments they're all capable of
collecting you know kind of the dimmest
of the gem cells virus the bright cells
the issue is in any one particular
exposure with the camera system but
you're not able to collect the full
breadth of both the dim cells and the
bright cells
so you're kind of intrinsically biasing
yourself either to
either looking for very very uh
high sensitivity but kind of blowing out
your linear range on bright cells um so
you're only going to really be
quantifying things like you know pdl-1
or p1
at the sacrifice of brighter signals
like you know uh cd4 cd8 just it's comic
examples um you really do have to take
multiple exposures over a
different exposure bracket and put that
all together to get a true idea of
what's going on within your samples we
found this is really really important
to
to really kind of specify where a cell's
phenotype or where the expression level
is truly lies kind of relative to the
actual biology that's going on as
opposed to just the signal of noise a
particular camera so bringing it outside
of just the physics of your instrument
requires multiple exposures
and to deal with those multiple
exposures most common uh tool to use is
hdr imaging hdr composition
great
all right looks like we have time for
one more question here so we'll go ahead
and wrap up with this one are the full
pipelines mentioned in the talk
available somewhere uh sure so the um
the internal pipeline the chip cytometry
uh so that that is uh kind of uh
proprietary to us but if you'd like to
take a look at how that kind of works um
if you go to our website uh
canopybiosciences.com and search through
uh to find our support page we have lots
of videos on you know kind of the the
inner workings of it um that will give
you a flavor for kind of how how uh
how things are going within the software
um the two examples that i did are i
presented as far as external uh software
third-party software uh those were done
in nis elements uh which is a software
package uh that's licensed through uh
nikon instruments um in that case you
know those
if you happen to also be an elements
user uh i can export and give you those
uh
give you those recipes uh so that you
can do um your own internal analysis
with our pipeline
um
for the q path and kind of the ones that
i mentioned there
um as far as kind of open source uh
solutions i definitely pointed towards
uh sebastian
rose a publication that he's just put
out on it was an a star method
as well as another
another publication where he goes
through and basically lays out a
pipeline that goes all the way from chip
cytometry data
to doing uh you know cluster analysis
all as one package so that's freely
available as well i might just take a
look at the reference uh within the
slide
fantastic
well thank you again spencer for your
time today and your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor canopy biosciences for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd also like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we do not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
laborats will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time take
care everyone goodbye
you